for more than a hundred years the
Democratic Party was organized around
the interests of ordinary Americans
Democrats ran campaigns on things like
higher wages better working conditions
against the banks that crushed their
voters with debt a lot of Democratic
ideas didn't always work somewhere silly
but their focus was always clear
American citizens were the party's
priority and that is no longer the case
to the modern Democratic Party Americans
are an afterthought try to find a
Democrat running this year for example
on the opioid crisis or high energy
prices the collapse of public schools
the decline of the middle class hard to
find one Democrats are bored by these
topics what interests them is power in
order to win and maintain power
Democrats understand they need reliable
new voters voters will support them
obediently without making difficult
demands like a higher standard of living
that's why the Democratic Party suddenly
supports open borders so fervently
immigration is really the only issue
that matters to them because packing the
electorate is the only way they can
regain control of this country their
goal is clear and they will do or say
anything to achieve it here for example
is the governor of New York likening the
Trump administration to Islamic
terrorists for the crime of daring to
enforce federal immigration law watch
they are on a jihad to deport as many
people as they can who they believe are
not in the United States legally who
they believe are not in the United
States legally pretty easy to determine
whether someone's here legally or not
and it wasn't that long ago that leading
Democrats like Bill Clinton for example
argued in public that our country should
deport illegal immigrants they're here
illegally after all they're breaking our
law now Democrats claim that
non-citizens even illegal ones have a
right to vote in our elections that is
happening in San Francisco and in parts
of the state of Maryland but the 2020
election it'll be happening in many
other places that's guaranteed now you'd
think congressional Republicans would be
upset about this
allowing illegals to occupy and run our
country makes a mockery of citizen
ship it's terrible for America and it's
a death sentence for the Republican
Party but no Republicans on the hill
seem okay with this here's one example
in 2014 the Obama administration changed
the rules so that anybody claiming a
threat from gang violence or domestic
abuse could get asylum in the United
States the effect was to allow pretty
much anybody to permanently enter this
country provided they supplied the right
story and many many did of course that
was precisely the point to open the
border so that saying so well earlier
this summer Attorney General Jeff
Sessions reversed the Obama rule now
House Republicans somehow for some
reason are teaming up with Democrats to
stop sessions from doing that just
yesterday they tacked an amendment onto
an appropriations bill in the house they
would preserve the asylum rights of
anybody who claims to be fleeing gang
violence that change would nullify any
effort to secure our southern border
Mexico and Central America have plenty
of gang violence now a hundred and fifty
million people who live there can cite
that fact as justification to move here
legally and stay permanently when they
get here they'll find Democrats eager to
give them the right to vote